[Musique]
si je te parlais d'elle la princesse
sans voix que dirais-je
[Musique]
elle est sourde muette elle peut t'entendre tu nettoies
ce labo pour sortir c'est peut
être l'atout le plus sensible jamais
logé  dans cet établissement,
vous pouvez penser que cette chose a l'air humaine
se tient sur deux jambes, mais nous sommes
créés dans le Lord Jim, vous ne pensez pas
que c'est ce que le Seigneur ressemble à moi,
cette créature est intelligente, capable
de langage pour comprendre les émotions
[Musique]
quand  il me regarde il ne sait pas à quel point
je suis incomplet il me voit tel que
je suis  belle
chose complexe détruite nous ne pouvions rien faire Je suis
désolé
ne fais pas ça alasa qu'est-ce que c'est - ne fais pas
ça ce n'est même pas humain
si je te parlais d'elle que dirais-je
je me demande
[Musique]